avec ça ils vont finir par améliorer ses
conditions à la prison la prison
les geôliers l'arbitraire et mène
derwiche les a vécu dans sa chair
en 98 à tunis lors d'une manifestation
étudiante contre les frais de scolarité
contre la présence de la police sur le
campus universitaire et contre le régime
du président ben ali
elle a été arrêté et torturé pendant
plusieurs jours c'est dans le noir se
sent un certain moment la bande ans et
je trouve c'est le pire sentiment qu'on
peut avoir
elle faisait face à plusieurs chefs
d'accusation et risqué 35 ans de prison
grâce à la mobilisation d'amnesty
international elle a été libérée au bout
de 18 mois
depuis elle participe chaque année à la
campagne de voeux des lettres elle en a
aussi reçu les cartes ca pour moi c'est
comme la lumière c'est la libération à
l'intérieur d'une prison cette année
amnistie internationale a choisi de
soutenir dix jeunes à travers le monde
âgés de 14 à 25 ans des tenues portées
disparues ou condamnés à mort
l'organisation plaide également la cause
des jeunes de la communauté autochtone
de grassy narrows en ontario ce marathon
d'écriture a prouvé son efficacité
on a un taux de succès jusqu'à présent
de 77%
les cartes sont écrites ici comme
partout à travers le monde sont
acheminés aux personnes et mène derwiche
a écrit une vingtaine de lettres à la
jeune nièce zaman ariane se battre avec
ce courage je sais pas ça me rappelle
une partie de ma jeunesse
cette jeune actrice iranienne s'est
opposé au port obligatoire du foulard
elle croupit en prison depuis le mois
d'avril veut voir plus que quiconque
iman connaît l'importance de cette carte
et leur impact sur les conditions de
détention des victimes
ici à sintra yade radio canada montréal